played here for Cape Brett [Applause]
making the Florida Panthers have
a special young goaltender in him
does it sort of works he got a stick on him
to disrupt the shot and Anton forsberg cleans
it up average year and usually about a dozen get
contracts brought back in by Jerry may who bounces
back and put forsberg does the splits himself
keeps that up with a pile up in front of him
and he hangs off gets it back around and played
ahead by Highmore plays that back to center ice
Lindell switch in with a Chance shoot scores
Anton Randell lifts it over the arm of forsberg
and Florida takes the early lead Bernard Docker
lost coverage by Highmore in London London's
gonna Escape right into this nice little pop play
option on the back door looks him off and then
decides to keep himself and give the Florida
Panthers a one-nothing lead for the preseason
who's called in front of that Branford
takes a return pass from Patterson and
shoots and through the traffic night makes
another stop off the leg of Branson and wide
the Army team Fort Batterson why is that rink
wide schmickle didn't shoot scores stuck that
right in the top corner literally and it's a
1-1 tie just had ever a laser beam that puck
still in the net stuck it it is they got to
pull it right out of the netting Tom of a
shot but this starts in the defensive Zone good
support now watch this pass by Drake Patterson
across the Zone saucer drops right on schmenkel's
Stick better angle of it which Mako skates right
into that little screenshot it just stuck it
right there it stuck it right in the top shelf
KD I don't know Ryder wines it please stop
by Night wow great save there on Josh Bailey
22 this event was supposed to be held
last preseason but there was some
covet delays that yeah causes team to be
postponed as Davison Works back English
the back pitch shut score Roby yarminty Fires
at home in the opening second to second period
and there it is again Greg Batterson
making things happen in the neutral
zone in the sloppy play here along the
wall but batherson gets in good position
here to get that puck looking for
options slides it back through the scene
Harry benty does the rest as he fires it better
than Jerry Mayhew Mayhew crisscross with Ashland
works it back in the slot and wise Taps that back
they couldn't [Applause] makes the pad stop there
Aspen was banging away at the point is Branch
trip Eric brastrop swings that back to Bailey
and Bailey has that hook checked Away
by Zach Delphia race for it now Delphi
bus in short-handed selfie and put that
line gonna stick it up on the way back
[Applause]
here's wise with it wise nothing ever may
you throws a package still down the puck
still lose that's not right here's wise
with it [Applause] thank you [Applause]
back in the corner for sort of for McAllister lots
of Puck movement keeping him back to McAllister to
go mouth he goes between the legs goes sort
of yeah he's very much that way yeah busting
his Glendale got the first three of goals Romans
where the wore the helmet and cage Chris Osgood
Bobby Osgood
he's out
with Aspen winds in throws it across that pass
was blocked by Bernard Docker trickles down to
the goal Mouse and forsberg 210 out of the
team and now Plato by McEwen as he Dives and
knocks out to center ice didn't work by Zach
McEwen who was second effort he hasn't played
a lot tonight it's an opportunity and does a
good job in the defensive Zone cousins up for
Lindell winding in shoot scores when Bill's got
two and the game is tied at two Anton lundell
has been the best player for the Florida
Panthers on the ice and skate right into it
cousins are going to slide it to him he
goes from outside inside [Applause] [Music]
that catches Tyler cleven flat-footed on the
play and lundell skates towards him Florida
pulls the line again but it's poked way back
Baptist and he's got shmiko with him here
comes Panthers it works and shoots short side
and Knight makes a save d plays it back across
picked up by klevitt moves it back in front
but a good chance there for another Yarmouth
shot Save Me by forceberg Benning the cousins
he shoots that was blocked by a mama [Applause]
[Applause]
score
tiptoe by Parker Kelly another one takes a 3-2
lead with a power play goal through traffic
Parker Kelly's gonna get credit for the goal
but this is all about Greg Patterson getting
around to Defender a little curl and drag right
there and through the seam underneath the Stick
of Joshua and Parker Kelly as Knight makes his
way to the floor to finish Wahlberg [Applause]
so six meters on five for Florida moves
out ahead and to the line but not out now
it's picked up by Matheson here he comes
Jake Patterson FD nip [Applause] [Music]
crazy
[Music] fitting there's a little bouncy pocket
the Blue Line sticks with it chips it to space
for himself skates into it and then just slides
it into the empty net for the fourth point
[Music] thank you and timelines down here and the
Ottawa Senators Win It by a final score of four
to two on a big night for Jake Matheson what's
nice to come home and have a night like that but
that's true to you right the family section
there which is great this is a nice gesture
here by both organizations to [Music]
sold out crowd that showed up [Music]
[Applause]
Panthers have had a busy schedule
they flew all the way up here for
this and then have to head right back
they've got three games against Tampa